Oh, where should I put this?
The famous wage gap statistic—that for the
same work women earn 77 cents on the dollar—that’s
bogus.
If employers could save 23 percent by hiring
women, they’d fire all the men!
The gap is just the difference between the
average wages of all working men and women.
It ignores factors that justify different
pay: type of job, hours worked per week.
When these are taken into account, the wage
gap all but disappears.
Now some equal pay activists acknowledge that
factors like college major, hours worked per
week—that these explain the gap.
But, they insist, women choose different major
and work fewer hours because of social pressure
and sexist stereotypes.
Well, it’s 2016, not 1960.
American women today are free to choose.
Why not respect their choices?
Now, I’m not suggesting that things are
perfect for women in the work place, but genuine
reform will come from truth, not myth.
If you want to see progress in the work place,
stop promoting the phony wage gap statistic.
What do you think we can do to stop the spread
of misinformation?
Let me know in the comments, and if you have
ideas for other topics I could cover in 60
Seconds tell me about that too!